there is this tribe in new guinea that
practices polygamy and when the husband
of three wives was asked how many wives
he wished he had everyone was expecting
him to say maybe six or seven but he
paused thought and said actually
none now i really cannot relate to this
man and that's not because i want to
have multiple wives but because i just
want a lot more of the things that i
enjoy in life the main thing being
knowledge and books a quick google
search showed me that there are
currently 130 million books in the world
so therefore it's no wonder that i
constantly feel like i'm missing out on
so much of them i constantly crave new
books i want to learn more read more
feel more experience more all the time
and this almost anxious curiosity leads
me to live my life at a rate that other
people around me find usually annoyingly
dizzying
i challenged myself to be a bit more
like this man and for the first time in
my life to just
calm down i usually tend to read about
three new books every single week but
for the last six months i've been
forcing myself to not read a single new
book but to only reread all the books if
i felt like it and honestly it's
completely changed my life so at the end
of this experiment here is how a
recovering new knowledge addict now
thinks that actually rereading books
might be much more valuable than reading
new ones and also how this has
potentially completely changed my
behavior from now on let's get straight
into it now the first thing i want to
get out of the way is that even though
i'm technically rereading a book the
thing that i've realized is that i can
never actually read the same book twice
because every time i'm reading it it is
completely different because i am
completely different i feel as though
the book is reading me just as much as i
am reading it now bruce also said this
when he said that in reality every
reader while he's reading is the reader
of his own self and this is because
every time i'm approaching a book i'm
approaching it with my background with
my history with my feelings with my
emotions with my traumas with my joys
with my pains with my perspective at the
moment which is consistently shifting
and this is really really interesting
because every time that i am different
the book that i'm reading is also
different and in a philosophical sense i
truly believe that no two people have
actually read the same book ever and
what is a book really and what did the
author meant and what i got was so
different because every time that i read
something what i'm reading is different
too cruz also said that one cannot read
a novel without describing to the
heroine the traits of the one that we
love and because often the one that i
love changes also the heroine changes so
the whole story in a way changes this is
so essential to what i'm taking from
books in general beyond the simple fact
that yes i'm kind of reading a different
book every single time what this really
means to me is that books become a
checkpoint to my growth and who i am as
a person because for example every time
that i read something i'm not only
laying down the memories of what i'm
reading in the book i'm also capturing
who i am as a person i'm capturing my
perspectives i'm capturing how the book
is making me feel i'm capturing how i'm
interpreting things in the book and if i
reapproach it a few months weeks or
years later i can remember not only what
i read at the time but also who i was at
the time and how i was thinking and so
every time that i'm reading a book when
it's the same book it's almost as though
i'm leaving an anchor or a checkpoint in
my life that will just be frozen there
in time and the next time i reread that
book i can vividly remember who i used
to be the last time i touched it and
this is so so interesting to me i found
that reapproaching books that i've read
years later highlighted the changes
between me as a person back then and who
i am right now and it's almost there was
a point a and now there is a point b and
i can see all the difference in between
and it's so so crazy mihaily chicks and
mihai said that we should always keep
exploring what it's like to be different
to who we are and i feel as though with
rereading books i've done this much more
intentionally because not only have i
passively changed but now i've realized
that changed and i've seen the
trajectory and the direction of my
growth which means i can either
re-evaluate and go in a different
direction or i can be happy or curious
about where i've come and how i've
changed in my life the second thing i
found by rereading books is that i've
turned from a what reader into a white
reader i feel like the first time i'm
approaching something i'm much more
focused on the information itself or on
the narrative and the story and a huge
part of my conscious and a huge part of
my brain is focused on what's actually
happening and where it's going to go and
kind of making these constant
assumptions about what's happening or
what will happen and then those being
either affirmed or turned down and so a
huge part of my attention is focused on
the information itself and very little
of it does this more why work of why is
this happening and what's going on but i
feel as though the second time i'm
reapproaching a book because i already
know what the story is i'm much more
free to do very exciting things with my
conscious mind i thought a lot about how
to describe this and the best way that i
can come up with is that when i'm
reading a book for the first time i'm
focusing on the words so my
consciousness is on the paper it's there
with what is happening but when i'm
rereading a book especially for the
third fourth or fifth time what happens
is that i'm neither in my mind and i'm
neither in the book but i'm somewhere in
between where i can somehow read between
the lines i can somehow kind of
transcend beyond the actual story and
the actual narrative and the actual
information into this state of being
able to question what is happening for
example the characters are no longer
people who do things but they are people
to whom things are done when i'm
rereading a fictional book for example i
like to focus a lot more on what is
happening with these characters i can
really point out all the points of
foreshadowing for example because you
can only see foreshadowing in
retrospective because i know what
happens to them in the future as i'm
seeing all the things that are
influencing them in the moment i'm
coming up for rules for human behavior
where i can see oh this is what
influences him later this is what makes
him do that think all the little details
here and there really build a very vivid
and stronger picture that i would never
be able to do on the first pass of a
book this in-depth understanding of
characters is so so valuable again chick
sent me high said when a writer explains
the failures of his characters in a way
he forgives himself too and this deep
deep cathartic understanding of human
behavior and of people that i can get
when i'm transcending the level of the
story is just so cathartic and so so
valuable and beautiful furthermore this
transcendence of the narrative into the
deeper meaning of the book means that i
am somehow passing the level of just the
words into the things that the writer is
not saying and the things that are
happening perhaps in the background that
are just not explicit eckhart teller
said that words turn reality into
something that human mind can grasp
which isn't much and this is quite funny
because everything in books comes from
words itself but i feel as though when
i'm rereading because i'm adding so much
from my perspective because i'm adding
things from the past of the book and the
future of a book that i've read in
previous readings everything comes
together in a much more powerful
powerful experience then i can get just
focused on the words one at a time as
i'm going through them in a first pass
also because i've read the book already
and i have a lot less anxiety and
especially in these six months i've gone
well you know i can read this as many
times as i want so it kind of quietened
my mind and helped me use one
perspective at a time when i'm reading a
book sometimes i will focus just on the
narrative of a secondary character or
sometimes i'll focus just on this little
bit of information that was said in a
corner of a story or in a corner of a
chapter and this perspective the
singular perspective one at a time was
so liberating and so much more powerful
i love the quote by brian christian
which i'm kind of shoehorning here but
it says that a man with one watch knows
what time it is and a man with two never
knows and i feel as though when i'm
reading a book i'm using multiple
watches so multiple perspectives from
all the characters from all the
complexity from all the things that i'm
bringing to it but when i am reading a
book again and again i can calm down and
just use one watch and one perspective i
just see things in a singular way that i
want to and get so much from it in that
way although my natural state of mind
tends to be quite scattered and having
multiple thoughts and perspectives at
the same time it's been quite
entertaining and an interesting break to
just commit to one perspective for a
while in a book that's honestly been
very very different and new for me so
i've really enjoyed it now this change
of perspective leads me very nicely onto
my third point which is how my
note-taking has changed because i still
take notes from a book no matter how
many times i've read it but they tend to
be so so different i feel like when i
take notes from a book on the very first
read they tend to be these sexy phrases
the quotes that i will use in these
videos for example and the things that
are just like blatantly obvious that
everyone is interested in and that i'm
interested in too but i feel as though
once this is done on a first or second
pass then i'm left with some really
really high level understanding and
honestly this has been crazy i've
accessed levels of note taking by
rereading books that i never even knew
were possible before for example in one
book in particular time enough for love
which is my favorite book of all time
there was this chapter which describes
someone's life story and when i was
taking notes on it what i did was i
created a i broke down this character's
life journey into specific points where
then i created a formula for his way of
living life if that makes sense which
was so bizarre i'd never i've reached
this level before so i feel as though
i've unlocked this ultimate level of
note-taking where i see the actual
frameworks or the patterns in the
behavior of the characters in fictional
books for example or see the bigger
picture bigger frameworks in non-fiction
books it's just been crazy so honestly
next level note-taking can be achieved i
think by rereading things again and
again the fourth way that rereading
books has kind of changed me is in the
dopamine comfort versus stimulation and
what i mean by this is that i think like
all people i'm quite a dopamine driven
person and equipment is a hormone which
kind of gives you pleasure when you are
anticipating a reward and i think this
is closely tied into why i love new
books because there is this part of my
mind that goes oh is this going to be
interesting is this going to be new and
this is going to be the potential reward
that i get every time that i read a book
and i feel as though this high level of
dopamine really really drives me to
power through really fast new
information new books anything that is
recommended and this is the kind of
reward that i always associated with
reading which i think is not the full
picture because i kind of remembered
when i was a lot younger for example i
used to love reading a lot but i used to
be
a prolific reader's understatement but i
used to read a lot and very fast to a
level that my parents could obviously
not keep up with so very often i had to
reread books almost all the time i had
like about 400 500 books and those were
the books that i would go through on
rotation i wasn't able to just buy new
ones all the time and as i became an
adult then i just had like more
disposable income and the internet and
so i can buy books really fast and
really easily and go through them as and
when i want which has kind of led me to
almost never reread things because i can
get the dopamine hit with novelty but i
think i realize that there is a dopamine
hit with comfort too what i mean by this
is that when i'm reading a book and
especially a fictional story or a
philosophy book what happens is that i
am creating a world in my mind and this
can either be like a physical world that
exists for example a harry potter world
i'll use that because i've reread harry
potter multiple times as a child and i
have this whole universe in my mind that
i can escape to there's this space which
has rules and characters and connections
and laws and i know i always know that
no matter how bad the real world gets i
have this opportunity and chance to
escape there in my mind because it's all
set up for me it's already it's very
very easy for me to just go there and
this is dopamine i think from comfort
because i know that i will get a reward
in this place that exists already in my
mind and the same way with philosophy
for example when there's a philosophy
book that really resonates with me it
provides this framework for viewing the
world that i know i can access every
time that i read this book so every time
i read this book i can put these lenses
on and see the world in this way that
the philosopher described and that's
also my comfort dopamine so i've gone
actually i should probably be doing this
more and i should not just let this be
you know harry potter and a few
philosophers but i should let this be
more books and every time that i kind of
get in touch with a book that i love and
i'll go no no i want to create a world
that i know i'm going to get a
guaranteed kind of comfort dopamine head
every time that i get this so i don't
know if this makes sense but it made
sense in my mind and my very last point
and i don't want to offend anyone but i
think i've become a bit of a book snob
by doing this because
honestly um throughout these six months
i've had basically
thousands of books from which i could
pick to reread that i've read already
and not once have i gone oh i want to
reread this pop psychology productivity
book never it's always been really good
works of literature or really good
philosophy books or something that's
just like a lot of dense information and
i've kind of wondered why the hell i
read so many shitty books because i feel
i feel quite torn with this because i
get recommended a lot of productivity
books and a lot of like pop books i
don't know how to describe them like how
to work faster or how to learn more or
how to i don't know these like modern
businessy type books and i get
recommended them a lot i read them
they're okay but they're just so
superficial and i think i've been
wasting a lot of my reading time reading
these and i don't know where i stand at
the moment a part of me goes just like
screw all that and go back to the
original text and read really really
good works of literature or really
really good like dense academic work
rather than reading these like
over-processed really flimsy books but
then another part of me goes well i mean
i guess i get some information from them
and it's good to be kind of in touch
with what everyone around me is going
through so i don't know i feel a bit
both ways but i've definitely become a
lot stricter now with realizing that
there's definitely a type of book that i
would never touch twice and that has
been the majority of books that i've
been reading for the last few years and
that doesn't make me feel too good so um
yeah i'm a bit torn on this one i would
love to hear your thoughts from all the
books i've been rereading um two that i
would definitely recommend are time
enough for love i kind of want to do a
full video on this because it's my
favorite book of all time and also a new
earth or an untethered soul and um short
form is a great place not sponsored
short firm is a great space to kind of
get a summary of these books and see if
they resonate with you if you want to
adapt this framework and then to kind of
invest in actually reading the full
thing which is obviously much more worth
it than anything else now reestablishing
my core knowledge and reasoning as an
adult is something which i feel very
very strongly for and i don't only use
books but i also love to use practical
exercises for for this i love to use
brilliant which are very kindly
sponsoring this video now i am lowkey
obsessed with the little dopamine hits
that i get from the logical questions on
brilliant which kind of i think at least
help me process through books a lot more
quickly and efficiently and if you are
an adult or just a stem student and you
would love to brush up on these
exercises with me there will be a link
in my description which will give you a
free trial or a discount depending on
what you want to do with it so yeah
thank you so much if you made it so far
i hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be count yourself on others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye